welcome to the presentation on moments
so just if you were wondering I have
already covered moments you just may not
have recognized it because I covered it
in mechanical advantage in torque but I
do realize that when I covered it in
mechanical advantage in torque I think I
may be over complicated it and if
anything I didn't cover some of the most
basic moment of force problems that you
see in in your standard physics class
especially physics classes that aren't
you know focused on calculus or you know
I'm going to make you a mechanical
engineer at the very next year so we we
did that with what I write down the word
mechanical oh yeah mechanical advantage
that's if you do a search for a
mechanical advantage I have I cover some
some things on moments and also on
torque so what is moment of force well
it essentially is the same thing as
torque it's just another word for it and
it's essentially force times the
distance to your axis of rotation what
do I mean by that let me take a simple
example let's say that I have a pivot
point here let's say I'm a pivot point
here let's say I have some type of some
type of seesaw or whatever there's a
seesaw and let's say that I were to
apply some force here and the forces the
forces that we care about and this was
the exact same case with torque because
they're essentially the same thing the
forces we care about are the forces that
are perpendicular to the distance from
our axis of rotation right so in this
case if we're here the distance from our
axis of rotation is this that's our
distance from axis of rotation so we
care about a perpendicular force either
a force going up like that or force
going down like that so let's say I have
a force going up like that
let's call that F f1 d1 so essentially
the moment of force created by this
force is equal to f1
times d1 or the perpendicular force
times the moment arm distance this is
the moment arm distance moment moment
arm that's also often called the lever
arm if you're talking about a simple
machine and I think that's what the term
I use when I when I did a video on
torque moment arm and why is this
interesting well first of all this force
times distance or this moment of force
or this torque if it has nothing
balancing it or no offsetting moment or
torque it's going to cause this this
seesaw in this example to rotate
clockwise right this whole thing since
it's pivoting here is going to rotate
clockwise the only way that it's not
going to rotate clockwise is if I have
something keep so right now you know
this descent is going to want to go down
like that and the only way that that I
can keep it from happening is if I exert
some upward force here so let's say that
I exert some upward force here that
perfectly counter balances that keeps
that keeps this whole seesaw from
rotating f2 and it is a distance d2 away
from our axis of rotation but it's going
in a counterclockwise direction so it
wants to go like that so the law of
moments essentially tells us and we
learned this when we talked about the
net torque essentially tells us that
this force times this distance is equal
to this force times this distance so f1
d1 is equal to f2 d2 or if you subtract
this from both sides you could get f2 d2
minus f1 d1 is equal to zero and
actually this is how we dealt with it
when we talked about torque because just
the convention with torque is if we have
a a counterclockwise rotation it's
positive and this is a counterclockwise
rotation and the example that I've drawn
here and if we have a clockwise rotation
it's it's an as a negative torque and
that's just the convention we did and
that's because torque is a pseudo vector
but I don't want to confuse you right
now what you'll see is that these moment
problems are actually quiet quite
straightforward so let's do a couple it
always becomes a lot easier
when you do a problem except when you
try to erase things with green so let's
say that let me let me plug in real
numbers for these values here let me
erase all of this let me erase some of
my let me just erase everything there
you go
all right let me draw a lever arm again
so what we learned when we learned about
torque is that an object won't rotate if
the net torque the sum of all of the
torques around it or zero and we're
going to apply essentially that same
principle here so I said if I have let's
say let's do it with masses because I
think that that helps explain a lot of
things and makes the seesaw example a
little bit more tangible let's say let's
say I have a five kilogram mass here
five kilogram and let's just say that
that gravity is 10 meters per second
squared right so what is the downward
force here
what is the downward force it's going to
be the mass times acceleration so it's
going to be 50 Newtons and let's say
that the distance the moment arm
distance or the lever arm distance here
and all let's say that this this
distance right here is 10 meters and
let's say that I have another mass I
don't know let's say it's a let's say
it's a 25 kilogram now that's too much
let's say it's 10 kilograms let's say I
have a 10 kilogram mass 10 kilogram mass
and I want to place it some distance D
from from the fulcrum or from the axis
of rotation so that it completely
balances this 5 kilogram mass so how far
from the axis of rotation do I put this
10 tilaka 10 kilogram mass this is the
distance right because we actually care
the center of the mass well how much
force is this 10 kilogram mass exerting
downwards well as 10 kilograms times 10
meters per second squared it's a hundred
Newton's so and then there this is
acting what this is acting clockwise
all right this one's acting clockwise
and this one's acting counterclockwise
all right so they are offsetting each
other so we could do it a couple of ways
we could say that 50 Newtons the moment
in the in the counterclockwise direction
50 Newton's times 10 meters in order for
this thing to not rotate has to be equal
to the moment in the clockwise direction
and so the moment in the clockwise
direction is equal to 100 Newton's 100
Newton's times some distance some
distance let's call that D 100 times D
and then we could just solve for D right
we get 50 times 10 is five hundred five
hundred Newton meters is equal to 100
Newton's times D that's 100 divide both
sides by 100 you get five meters is
equal to D so D is equal to five and
that's interesting
and I think this kind of confirms your
intuition from playing at the playground
that you can put a heavier weight closer
to the axis of rotation to offset a
light weight that's further away or the
other way to put it is you could put a
light weight further away and you kind
of get a mechanical advantage in terms
of offsetting the heavier weight so
let's do a let's do a a more a more
difficult problem I think the more
problems we do here the more sense
everything will make so let's say let me
let me let's say that we have a bunch of
masses let's say that we have a bunch of
masses actually let's not do it with
masses let's just do it with forces
because I want to complicate the issue
so this is the pivot and let's say I
have a force here that's 10 Newtons
going in the clockwise direction and
let's say it is it is that let's say if
this is zero let's say that this is at
minus 8 so this distance is 8 all right
let's say that I have another force
going down at 5 Newtons
and let's say that its x-coordinate is I
don't know minus six let's say I have
another force that's going up here and
let's say that it is 50 Newtons this
might get complicated 50 Newtons and
it's at minus two so it's this distance
right here is two right now let's say
that I need to figure out let's say that
I have a not making this up on the fly
let's say that I'm have another force
here that is 5 Newton let's make it a
weird number 6 Newtons and this is this
distance right here is 3 meters and
let's say that I need to figure out what
force I need to apply here upwards or
downwards I actually don't know because
I'm doing this on the fly to make sure
that this whole thing doesn't rotate
right so to make sure this whole thing
doesn't rotate essentially what we have
to say is is that all of the
counterclockwise forces all of the
counterclockwise moments or all of the
counterclockwise torques have to offset
all of the clockwise torques so what are
all and then notice they're not all on
the same side so what are all of the
things that are acting in the
counterclockwise direction so counter
clockwise is that way right so this is
acting counterclockwise this is acting
counterclockwise and that's it right and
so the other ones are clockwise and we
don't know this one let's assume let's
assume for a second well let's assume we
could assume either way and if we get a
negative that means it's the opposite so
let's assume that this is a that bit and
so let me all of the clockwise ones all
doing this dark brown so this is
clockwise let's assume that this is
clockwise and let's assume that our
mystery force is also clockwise right so
all the clockwise moments have to offset
all of the counterclockwise moments have
to offset all of the clockwise moments
so what are the clock what are the
counterclockwise moments well this one's
counterclockwise so it's 10 Newton's 10
times its distance from its moment arm
we said it's 8 right because it's the
x-coordinate minus 8 from 0 so it's 10
times 8 plus 50 right this is also
counterclockwise times 6 50 times 6
and that was all those are all of our
counterclockwise moments and that has to
equal the clockwise moment so clockwise
moments let's see we have five Newton's
that is going clockwise times six five
Newton's actually was this was the six
know if this is six I must have written
some other number here that I can't read
now how far did I say this was I know
let's say that this is two so that 50 is
let's say that this is two it's negative
two because that's what it looks like
I apologize for confusing you so what
we're all the clock counterclockwise
moments this 10 Newton times its
distance 8 the 50 Newton's times this
distance - and don't get fused by the
negative I just kind of said we're in
the x coordinate axis or minus 8 if this
is zero but it's 8 units away right and
this 50 it's it's moment arm distance is
2 units and so that has to equal all of
the clockwise all of the clockwise
moments so the clockwise moments is 5
Newton's times 6 right its distance is 6
and it's 5 Newton's going in the
clockwise direction and then we have
plus 6 Newton's times 3 plus 6 times 3
and then we're just assuming we don't
know for sure our force our force and
let's say we're applying the force I
should have told you ahead of time so
you can do this problem let's say that
we're applying the force set at 10 units
10 meters away from our fulcrum arm so
force times 10 so now let's just solve
for the force we get 80 plus 100 is
equal to 30 plus 18 plus 10 F we get 180
is equal to 48 plus 10 F what's 180
minus 48 it's 32 132 so we get 132 is
equal to 10 F or we get F is equal to
thirteen point two Newtons so if we
apply so we guessed correctly that this
is going to be a clockwise sorry this is
going to be a I when I keep mixing
mixing up all over clockwise and
counter-clockwise Latia that this this
is going to be a clockwise force right
these were all of the
this is going to be a counterclockwise
voice right o'clock this is
counterclockwise so all of these let me
label that because I think I said it
wrong several times in the video so
these are the these go clockwise
clockwise and it's this one and this one
and what were the counterclockwise these
go counterclockwise so we have to apply
a 13-point 10 Newton force 10 metres
away which will generate 132 Newton
metres moment in the counterclockwise
direction which will perfectly offset
all of the other moments and our lever
will not move anyway I might have
confused you with all the
counterclockwise clockwise but just keep
in mind that all the moments in one
rotational direction have to offset all
the moments in the other rotational
direction and all a moment is is the
force times the distance from the
fulcrum so Force Times distance fulcrum
arm force times distance forearm I'll
see you in the next video